I am
back. Uh, we still have the same
problem. We still have the exact same
weird. So, is this like some cache in
the Docker container itself or
something?
right? Like it's clearly like something
wrong with the whole
system. Like look, X doesn't
load. I have internet.
I mean, this would just be cash,
wouldn't it?
Yeah. I like something's got to be
weirdly cached or like Right. I don't
know what the hell else it would be.
I mean, it's like I have
internet, but it's not just browser
cache because I'm getting it here on
this Syon file as
Well, everything is like super slow even
though it says I have good speeds.
But why would this have just suddenly
freaking broken
today? Isn't that
bizarre? Like I got an internet
blip. Oh, maybe my router did something
weird because there was like an internet
blip,
right?
1270.1? I should be able to get to
my my
I really prefer not to have to reset the
router if I don't have
to. But like I can't look at this. I
can't even get to it.
Oh no, I'm dumb. 192. Yeah. Yeah, I'm
just
dumb. Doesn't let me log in either,
which is kind of jank.
router. I want to have to reset the damn
router.
I'm just going to turn it off and back
on again instead of actually trying to
doom too much. I'll be back in a few
minutes. I guess today is just internet
janitor work.